I've got some new tour dates to announce
April 25th in Phoenix Arizona the
celebrity theater
um that's a new show that's been added
also May 11th Westbury New York
outside of New York City and July 2nd
Las Vegas
at The Encore Theater
the other show there is sold out those
tickets are available now at theovan.com
t-o-u-r we now have be good to yourself
crewnecks available in light blue maroon
and cement that embankment gang color
you know it check these out along with
the new windbreaker at
theovonstore.com and thank you for your
support
today's guest I mean this lady's got
that I mean
she got the voice of just
I mean you want to climb in her throat
and just
and just start a family
or knit an American flag you just want
to dang just Betsy Ross around her
tonsils baby she's just
I mean shh
she has a Timeless voice
it sounds like it just comes out of the
core of the Earth
and just pumping it
it's just like a beautiful train just
rolling three years she's got it
she won the female vocalist of the year
at the 2022 Country Music Awards
she's also an actress you may have seen
her on the show Yellowstone her new
album bell bottom country is out now and
uh I'm just
I'm grateful to be spending some time
with her getting to know her
today's guest is Laney Wilson
[Music]
tell you my story
[Applause]
yeah when things get busy it's
interesting how they get you don't know
who you're talking to you don't know
what you just did a line or for you
don't know what's going on it's crazy
and I'll I'll like thought people were
kind of full of it when they're like I
don't I didn't know what city I was in I
didn't know what day it was yeah it's
true
oh sometimes I'll be halfway through the
statement uh what's up and I will have
to check in my head do you know what
this is there's times where I all day
long I'm like all right I'm in Salt Lake
I'm in Salt Lake I get up there and I'm
like
where am I you know
yep yeah it's kind of it definitely gets
it can be kind of challenging I think
just because of how quick things how
quick things happen and how busy you can
get
um can you move this a little bit in and
down
yeah but you can also move it if you
feel like I want you to feel okay yeah
oh look if you want to let loose
something I can unscrew oh I love it I
love your voice
thank you yeah it's really nice thank
you very much um it's a gift I feel like
to the whole world I'm sure a lot of
people feel that way I feel like when
you're singing like somebody's singing
from like
I feel like somebody's singing from the
past I mean I feel like it's coming from
like yeah I just feel like they're it's
like coming from another
I'll take that thank you like plain or
something I'm like it's almost like
sometimes I feel like I was born in the
wrong decade really yeah I mean who
knows what I was doing in a in a
previous life but I yeah I've kind of
have some weird feelings like that too
so yeah yeah like do you think of a time
like do you feel like there's a time
like
do you get a sense of what is going on
around you at that time if it was a past
I mean
I don't know what it was
um
but I do feel I do feel like a little
bit of an old soul
I don't know I don't know if it's which
I have some family members and stuff who
I think kind of feel the same way so
maybe it's just something like a little
thing kind of passed down but yeah I
wonder who I was who was that yeah who
were you who were you oh I know who you
could have been you could have been like
a trained conductor but before they had
a whistle so you had to also be the
whistle so you had to be like uh-huh
like you had to really belt it out you
know I'm just trying to think of
something where you'd also have to be
like real verbose and like let them know
you know yeah
and what if people would have come or
what if somebody else was a conductor
and you just were you were the horn like
they didn't no I was a caboose don't
even play I was I was the Caboose I have
seen some videos on tick tock
without
people really coming for that romp huh
coming for The Romp I'm like I've been
in Nashville for 12 years trying to do
music and here we are the butt goes
viral and I mean they they find the
music through the butt and they plan on
sticking around but
it's uh yeah I'm trying to embrace it
yeah nothing will keep a man around like
some bud I think that's right that's
right I'm like whatever whatever makes
them listen to the music yeah hey look
sometimes they start with the bass
section you know before they get to the
trouble you know that's yeah that's
exactly it I think that's all it is I
think that's all it is too I mean I
didn't know how to feel about it in the
beginning I was like
I thought it was gonna be just this
little little tiny viral thing and next
thing I know weeks later I'm still
seeing
big old butts yeah what was that can you
pull that up uh Ben
if you find that Tick Tock I don't even
know I just remember seeing that it was
like um
some yeah it was like a side angle if
you want to stage and and then with the
leopard pants yeah now that'll probably
be it was like an optical illusion I
don't think my butt's really that big I
think it was the leopard I mean maybe
the leopard had a big butt oh my God
that is see wow that was that was a good
day
also this is a wide screen let's be
honest I mean look I'm just saying y'all
doing me dirty this is 16.9 baby I think
whatever that is
you got that Silver Screen rear dang
that thing is uh it's out there yeah
that cheetah must have been strong
what's what's weird is people like
where'd you get that from and I say I
get the the width from my mama and the
depth from my Daddy really my Daddy's
got a he got a little booty on it does
he yeah yeah
I used to date a girl actually and she
had her father's butt oh my God yep and
it was always like I don't know it was
so hard for me sometimes to
like want to mate with her sometimes
because you're just thinking about her
father's day I wasn't thinking about her
father but it was like a very distinct
looking buttocks you know I gotta say
this girl's butt I mean she was
beautiful but she had she had her
father's butt kind of I think I mean I
don't know I shouldn't even say that I
don't know what was going on she
listened to this too and she knows
exactly She's like Yeah he talking about
me I hope not
um
congratulations on on your uh two top
you have two songs in the top ten right
now right which is crazy but it's about
trucks yeah both about trucks like a
truck I know so so uh
yeah I mean it's just amazing and you're
I just want to start like because some
some audience might not know you right
so I want to start well let's look at
this Tick Tock let's look at it real
fast all right because there's a bunch
of them I want to see it again and who
is that guy I don't know but there's a
lot of different versions
oh yeah
yeah this was opening for Morgan this
past summer I had been eating real good
this summer you know hey come on
yeah they look like frog legs almost
right there with those pants in a way I
don't know if you know what I'm saying
well you look lovely that's awesome oh
my gosh that's the security guard down
there in the corner he like oh he's
still writing letters to you oh yeah
he's probably in a minimum security
facility right now
um you are originally we're both from
Louisiana I know that's cool different
parts of Louisiana but yeah you're up
from you're from I'm from Northeast so
like about 30 miles south of Monroe okay
a little town called Baskin of like 200
people oh wow you're from Covington area
yeah I'm from Covington so and Baskin is
that near because I used to work up near
Natchez I worked on a farm in outside of
Natchez up near like not today matches
and Vidalia and inferiority yeah we had
a good time over there Alexandria yeah
we go to like where is it okay there we
go Baskin dang that's it my God yup yup
there it is you blink and miss it we
have a a caution light and what's the
caution for is what if somebody is there
a miss somebody who missed it is a speed
trap when I tell you if you go through
Baskin you better slow down oh God I got
my first speeding ticket
at 15 years old and Baskin I had to go
to court of course there's nothing for
them to do they have to give you
attention well we got to do we go gotta
pay the bills
but yeah I've been in Nashville for
almost 12 years
um got here August 1st 2011.
in a little camper trailer did you yep I
lived in a camper the first three years
I was here
and uh I'm just too hard-headed to leave
honestly I don't know how to do anything
else this is it yeah is singing now do
you sing do you also play and you play
instruments yeah yeah I play the guitar
I can play a little bit of piano by ear
but um
yeah I love it my daddy taught me a few
chords on the guitar and wrote my first
song at nine years old
I knew I mean my family took me on a
trip when I was nine it was like a
couple weeks after I had written my
first song and we were driving back home
to Louisiana and we drove through
Nashville I remember where I was on the
interstate I was looking at the Batman
building and I told my mom and daddy I
said this is home I just knew it really
I knew it I knew that I was going to be
a part of of this industry I just didn't
know when or what that was going to look
like and yeah this is that has always
been a plan wow
um and so when you're starting so you're
a child and how do you get into music I
mean obviously Louisiana there's a lot
of like music passing through there
that's right you could have a you know a
sip of of a local hose and you'll you
know you you might have a couple notes
just get laws genuine it's definitely
it's in the world there what uh how did
that kind of start for you I mean did
your mother or father play Daddy played
a little mama bless her heart she can't
carry a tune in a bucket I'm talking
about like she sings the loudest in
church like even Jesus getting mad about
that he's like looking down like that's
of the devil that's up the devil
um but she loves music she loves to
dance
um on both sides of my family I have
people who play like musical instruments
and stuff but in Baskin I mean country
music is more than just a genre it is
truly a way of life and so growing up
you know listening to a lot of 90s
country I just we eat sleep and breathe
it yeah we talk about music we'd sit
around if I was riding the tractor with
daddy like that's what we were listening
to and it was really a soundtrack
to our lives
and so I I didn't even realize as a
little girl that country music was like
a genre of music I thought it was just
you know best music I should see it yeah
wow
that's interesting and what about for
you down there
well what I'm trying to think of the
first song I ever even heard I think was
Bon Jovi
yeah and I was lit like uh this
babysitter was giving me a ride to YMCA
Camp and she played it and I'd never
been like in a car like with a woman
before that wasn't my mother and so I
think it like everything seemed so like
real yeah yeah yeah so my memories were
like very alive you know and so I just
remember being there and
she let me put her seat belt on or I
remember it oh my gosh because I think I
was like a I was like you know we got to
be safe we gotta be safe let me buckle
you up yeah so I think she put mine on
and I was like oh let me put yours on
you know and then when I put hers on I
was like kind of close to like her body
and so I remember like oh man so then I
was like let's put yours on again right
I just remember I kept like let's
unbuckle we didn't do this the right way
let's do it again so I put a receiver on
like seven times and then finally she um
we start driving and she put on Bon Jovi
and I just remembered hearing that was
like the first song I ever heard really
um
the first time I ever heard a woman sing
that I remember I was in high school and
they had I'm sure I heard stuff on the
radio but
um some girl in our talent show at
school played like a jewel song Oh yeah
and it was like
dude I like didn't even know what was
going on like I was like mesmerized oh
mesmerized
it was just like because I never it just
was so beautiful it was like it was like
a woman just sitting there playing the
piano and singing and it was oh yeah I
fell in that feeling yeah did you play
in like talent shows and stuff at school
was that I mean what was school I mean
if 200 people are in town how many were
in school I had to go over to the town
next to me okay um there was a
elementary school in Baskin and my mama
taught there my granny was a principal
and
um but even going over to the town next
to me I mean I still I only graduated
with 24 kids and that was one of the
biggest classes they've ever had wow so
you know everybody everybody knows you
and it's like the the best thing and the
worst thing you know yeah
they'll be there no matter what but
they'll be there no matter what right
right yeah it's so small I guess huh yep
like did you so was was I guess it was
the kind of town you probably had to
have like a boyfriend from like a young
age was it like that kind of town yes I
mean I dated the same boy for seven
years wow that's so popular in those
type of communities I know it really is
and now like when I see like if I have a
songwriter buddy or whatever if he's got
like a daughter and and I've realized
they've been in this relationship for a
long time I'm like tell her not to do
that yeah like Let Go sew some Wild Oats
you know like at the end of the day you
might end up together right but there's
a big old possibility that you were
gonna change you're gonna be a
completely different person I mean I'm a
different person than I was five years
ago so
you just change yeah 100 and so did you
go to like prom was it like all of that
like it was like all the same boyfriend
huh yeah wow well there was one year
where uh we had broke up for a couple
months and I went to five proms that
year at that point I was just asking I
was like anybody need a prom date I'll
go with you but
um so I want to go back a little bit to
like just like when you were growing up
like what was it like like was it uh so
your mom worked at the school yep and
what'd she teach over there um well she
taught second grade for a while and then
she taught the gifted and talented
program she did and so she loved that
um and my daddy he's a a banker and a
farmer he does like crop loans for
farmers and
um Farms corn wheat soybeans oats
I mean they had us doing stuff all the
time
it's crazy how much like growing up on a
farm taught me just about life yeah in
general I mean you get up every day I
mean even when it comes to you know what
you do you get up every day you
roll your sleeves up you have good years
you have bad years oh they have several
it's a tough that is a tough business I
mean some a tornado could roll through a
flood a locust anything out the second
half of the Bible all of that comes
through it does and then you gotta worry
about the the all the loan side of it
the financial side of it that's right
yeah I remember when I would work on a
farm we would get up yeah we'd roll out
at like 6 30.
and people were like yeah you just eat
like gas station food until you got to
lunch and then lunch was kind of a big
if you had a nice deal unless like you
were planning then you had a pretty
decent lunch oh yeah and when I got home
I literally I remember laying down was
the first time I ever just and then just
woke up the next day it was like oh you
were tired I was tired yeah yeah it was
nice I know we used to like during the
Summers when I was too little to
actually help do anything daddy would
never let me plant because he knew I'd
mess that up but he would let me disc up
the fields and stuff like that but we
would take food out to the field and let
the tailgate down and kind of that would
be our little picnic table and have all
the farmers come out and
it's it's a a good childhood memory yeah
I bet yep
do you remember
um
like having like a real
like like connection to any female
singers when you were young like was
there anybody that really was like I
mean Dolly Parton oh yeah everything
about the woman I mean
just the way that she carries herself I
feel like she don't let anybody run over
her
um she kind of tells it how it is with a
like a little bow wrapped on top you
know yeah she's just incredible
singer-songwriter I've actually never
even met her really but um I think I
could I've learned a lot from her by not
meeting her so I can't imagine how much
I would actually learn from her if I sat
down with her and
yeah some advice I mean that would be
absolutely insane but yeah her
um and I love Leanne Womack I love I
just love 90s country
um everybody from
Shania to Reba to Trisha Yearwood like I
feel like those Faith Hill those were
the voices that
were around yeah
what did Leanne Womack sing I Hope You
Dance oh yeah the fool I remember the
first time I heard I hope you dance I
was in sixth grade and
my teacher came in with a little Boombox
on her shoulder and she played it and
even in the sixth grade I remember how
that song made me feel and I was like
whatever this feeling is like I want to
make other people feel that way wow
that song yeah music's so wild like that
I I realized that in the past year that
a lot of music it's like
you sometimes you can't put into words
what you're trying to say right and a
song will do that it's like it it's like
uh it's just such a gift because it'll
do that for you it's crazy yeah I mean I
have a hard time completing you know
full sentences but I can write a dang
song like but I bet I don't know if out
of bask and if y'all could if everybody
would have got together in a meeting if
y'all could have put a sentence together
no no no but I don't know I'm just
saying Louisiana dude you know how it is
oh bro you will see it I mean there were
I remember one kid turned in a paper and
had no punctuation in it one time in our
class that sounds about right and the
teacher even showed it to everybody
she's like I've just never seen anything
like this I mean that's how we talk yeah
right how we talk
but I love how I mean there's so many
different like dialects and stuff in
Louisiana I feel like from where where
you're at it's way different than where
I'm from oh yeah where you guys it's a
lot more farming up there yes it's a lot
more I feel like
young gestation I want to kind of say
like you know a lot more youthful people
get you know pregnant and blaming it on
God but really they're seeing somebody
that's right you know I feel like
there's a lot more
um just kind of secret like I don't know
what I'm trying to say no I agree I feel
like south Louisiana folks kind of just
leave it out there yeah what you see is
what you get and for some of the north
Louisiana folks too it's that way but
there's also a little bit of that like
we're gonna act like it ain't happening
kind of thing
yeah I act like the Lord's and really oh
yeah
the Lord made me cheat he he asked me to
you know
and the Lord bought me another drink
because Lord he did it he spoke to me
yep I've been there
yeah I'm trying to think of um do you
remember going so if you went to like a
high school dance where'd you go to that
at
um at the school at the I mean we got
that like Winnsboro or something where
were you guys in Winnsboro winsboro
Winnsboro that's where I went to school
yeah we used to go I think to a grain
elevator there I'm trying to think what
did we do there we went oh yeah there
was grain elevators was there oh yep
yeah when I was working on that farm we
would go up there to drive maybe it was
to work uh something like that yeah we
go to Winnsboro there's a big old grain
elevator right there in the middle of
town across from the Walmart
yep Deer Park where else would we go to
I don't remember
um not many people know winsboro so I'm
surprised that that's why I didn't even
say oh yeah
yeah that's wild
um well we go up there yeah sometimes
they're like I feel like that was it I
don't remember that well
but it was fun man yep I enjoyed it one
time I was because it always I was just
like a a hand you know on the farm so I
would just do whatever yeah and uh one
time I had to paint this house and I was
worried about the bees getting me right
because they had a lot of bees out there
so uh yeah there you go right there
green elevator baby that's it put that
grain away boy
[Music]
um
and so I put I made this visqueen suit
right out of like this queen and duct
tape right yeah so I got on the slider
and I'm painting and these bees are like
hitting me and I'm just like Invincible
right but what I don't realize is the
heat it was probably maybe 94 or
something oh shoot so suddenly I start
to see like at the bottom of my like
these like feet I made on the suit
because I went really in on this suit it
was pretty nice there's just like water
kind of pouring out of it like where
where does water and and then I just
realized I was just losing water yeah
and uh and it was bad man they put me in
a tub of ice at launch and oh my gosh
people were scared yeah and you guys
praying I'm like dude call the police
pray bro you don't say like I respect
the prayer but also text 9-1-1 this
guy's lighting candles and stuff call
911 yeah
so we had a little bit of a different
plan
you know I like keeping my hair you know
that I'm a hair boy
and I'm a hair man
and I want to tell you what helps me is
keeps
you know uh getting dialed in and being
on a program makes me at least feel
better
in addition to medically helping me
with what's going on
more than 50 million men in the U.S
suffer from male pattern baldness
keeps offers a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair via
expert recommended hair loss treatment
that's right personalized treatment
plans that are recommended by a licensed
medical provider and delivered straight
to your door you don't have to sneak
into an alley or go visit a little hair
wizard somewhere underground or
something like that
they offer 24 7 care and support and
it's low cost with keeps treatment plans
are affordable typically half the cost
of Pharmacy prices that's right whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered it has me covered
remember remember prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to get your
first month free
keeps.com slash Theo I like to start my
new year off with uh planning
this year my goals were to vape no more
and to have a morning routine
some of you may be uh wanting to budget
better
and if that's part of your year plan I
can tell you
that a credit card consolidation loan
from lightstream can help you pay off
your credit cards and lock in a low
fixed interest rate
that's right rates start at seven point
nine nine percent APR with autopay and
excellent credit
plus the rate is fixed so it will never
go up over the life of the loan that's
it you can get a loan from five thousand
to one hundred thousand and there are
absolutely no fees just for my listeners
apply now to get a special interest rate
discount from light stream and save even
more the only way to get this discount
is to go to lightstream.com Theo that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash
t-h-e-o subject to credit approval rates
range from 7.99 APR to 23.99 APR and
include a 0.55 zero percent auto pay
discount lowest rates require excellent
credit terms and conditions apply and
offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com Theo for
more information
um do you remember like going to like a
high school dancer like being in love
when you were young like what was that
kind of like a [__] show yeah yeah it's
like a drama like I thought that's how
it was supposed to be you know like you
fight for each other no you don't oh
yeah yeah you don't have to fight for
each other really you really don't
and it took me a long time to to realize
that but uh that's kind of the mentality
in some of those you know small towns oh
yeah I think there's so much like
um
I'm losing all my words today but
there's like a lot of stuff that's kind
of romanticized so it's like you know we
gotta do this I got a tiger by the tail
let's go you know
so yeah
um it was but high school for me was
it was fun
um I will say that I'm not friends with
hardly any of the people that I
graduated with just because we're living
completely different lives I might there
might be another person out of my
graduating class that's not married with
kids
um right were you a loner
no I wasn't a loner like I had like
girlfriends and stuff like that and
um but man just like we were talking
about earlier like people change things
change and sometimes you figure out who
people really are
and it sucks yeah
um
but I will say looking back on it now
um I wouldn't change it for anything if
anything it kind of gave me that boost I
needed to be here in Nashville because I
might still have you know oh man I need
to go I need to go back there and and
hang out with my with my girls and you
know having those ties or still dating
that same old boy yeah it kind of gave
me that push of like no you get out
there and you and you start your own
life like I spent a handful of nights in
my bed last year here in Nashville wow
so so you're on the road that much then
every between that and filming
Yellowstone and
um
yeah we are on the we're on the road a
lot but we're trying to you know burn up
the road strike when the Iron's hot and
go take advantage of this viral
Tick-Tock ass thing going on is that
really what you feel like is kind of I'm
just fighting okay but it's a little bit
it's interesting how you get onto
people's Radars it's so hard to get onto
people's Radars I know I know what kind
of stuff do you follow on tick tock oh
my gosh
um I followed like a few of my friends
like my songwriting friends Mega McCree
been Chapman I love looking at their
stuff
um but I follow like stupid stuff I love
like watching people fall down I love
um I love watching like little puppy
videos you know it depends on what kind
of mood I'm in and every now and then
I'll be scrolling I'll get some you know
like somebody preaching at me and then
I'll get into that and I'll be like you
know if you watch the whole thing you're
gonna get another one I'm like oh the
Lord he trying to
he getting me oh yeah I thought of God
is my girlfriend's sweatshirt the other
day off of somebody that I ended up on
some link and now I got that coming I
just hope it's not too small because I
feel like that's not the sweatshirt no
no no no
absolutely not yeah that needs to be a
big one
um yeah I'm trying to think what I watch
I follow a couple of like like uh people
that have like disabilities for somehow
a lot of people like if like now it used
to like now people kind of champion if
somebody in their family has a
disability you know
um so I follow a couple of folks like
that I follow this little baby named
samaj this little black child who is so
just adorable with his mother yeah
they're all he's always he always says
he has to go to work and then he has to
go to his second job
um what else do I follow yeah I get it
sometimes the Lord will yeah the Lord
yeah he'll stop you dead and you try
you'll be like watching something you
ain't supposed to be watching and then
the next one will be like
stop this one's for you don't scroll you
know
oh
um I don't know so then what is uh
what has what was like a first job that
you had growing up did you have a job
you said oh yeah I impersonated Hannah
Montana oh you did really I really did
for five years no way I started in the
eighth grade I would do like three or
four parties a weekend
but whose parties were if there's only
200 people in town oh no I went
everywhere it's so the first party I did
was uh for my eighth grade teacher and
she had just bought me a little Hannah
Montana wig and she's like will you just
show up to my little girl's party and
pretend to be Hannah and I just took it
too far and went and bought the karaoke
track I already had a portable sound
system and so I put on a show on a
flatbed trailer and when I tell you it
spread like wildfire wow next thing I
know I mean I'm playing in Mississippi
and Arkansas Texas the last place I did
it was at St Jude
um like I would open up the show or I
would at least ask like I can't Laney
open up the show and they're like who's
that and I'm like person you hired to do
this job
so oh so you would do both characters
yeah
I would try to because I'm like let me
take advantage of this
um let me just get up there with my
guitar and see if they like my stuff
yeah that's a great idea
so yeah I did that for five years I
played with did you ever get to perform
it for Miley or no I've never met Molly
you haven't but we got to do something
together at some point because I mean I
can't get away from the cyruses the
first song I learned on guitar was Achy
Breaky Heart oh so
yeah it's Gotta happen
I might as well be Osiris at this point
my egg yeah I met some guy that day I
think dated one uh that dated Molly for
a while the other day at a party
somewhere but uh I don't know if I've
ever met her no maybe I met one of her
sisters
um she's got a lot of siblings huh yeah
there's a lot of Cyrus's keep popping
yeah
okay like okay Ricky Cyrus yeah all
right I don't know about that you know
like okay Deontay Cyrus I don't that
sounds Deontay yeah everybody's trying
to be a sign yeah I feel like a lot of
this it could be a lot of FO Cyrus's
going
um
I did a lot of like I'll say whenever I
first moved to Nashville yeah um when I
was living in my camper trailer
um I'm living there with a man you're
living here by yourself by myself oh
dang yeah yeah yeah yeah you have a
security item yeah ah so long story
short
um there was a guy from Baskin who
wanted to move to Nashville and do music
and he ended up becoming a songwriter
producer and had some success like
in the 90s okay but he wanted to move in
the late 70s and uh my grandfather on my
daddy side he gave him just like a few
hundred dollars to kind of help him move
to Nashville and get started so as a
favor in return well he was my mentor
kind of growing up he'd stop by my house
whenever he came home to Baskin and
stuff and okay
um
he let me live in his Studio parking lot
out in Bellevue
for free for three years so I hooked up
the trailer to the water the Wi-Fi the
electricity I mean I flooded the thing I
was having uh
Plumbing issues and nobody wanted to
help me work on the thing so you know
I've got my daddy on the other line and
he's like we'll do this close off your
valves fill up your tank then you know
let it run for a while undo it and let
it kind of flush out while I fell asleep
and
the entire dining camper trailer flooded
it's uh I mean the floor eventually
started rotting out you know you just
had to be careful where you were
stepping yeah jump over the other part
to get to the bathroom you know oh yeah
it's like Dance Dance Revolution kind of
in there at a certain point you know
especially in a bad trailer don't when
they start to go they start that's right
yeah I mean the whole thing needed to be
redone and
um I remember one time I was I was
taking a shower and um I had just
started these like
kickboxing lessons or it was some
something called hot box here in town
where it's like super hot but you're
boxing and um
you know what it is you've been there I
mean I used to I've been super high in a
very small yeah yeah yeah you know what
hot boxing is like the other hot box
yeah and I've not been able to get out
so yeah I've freaked out before one time
in a truck and yeah almost kicked my way
out of a window of a well yeah well
that's the way I felt because how a
camper trailer
um shower doors are they've got the
little latch on it so you can close it
when you're traveling it's not like
flinging open and I remember I was
sitting there showering and it was ankle
deep water my propane was running out so
the water was cold my shower head fell
off I'm showering with a water hose and
then I'm like you know what this is some
[__] but whatever so
I try to you know I'm just like I'm
gonna get out of the shower and it's
gonna be a better day I get to go you
know push on that door that dang latch
it closed no I was stuck in there but
you know what them kickboxing lessons
came in handy because I wow right out
wow God dang
oh put that cheek in there Boo get that
leopard leg I did I sure did uh-huh
don't mess with me
dang dude I'm trying to think of uh yeah
my sister I live in a trailer for a long
time and she was so funny because like a
branch fell in their trailer right in
Louisiana she live out in Gonzales and
she had such a positive attitude like
one day she sends me a picture there's a
branch through their kitchen right
through the kitchen
and like one of her kids is like sitting
on the other side of the counter eating
cereal like they're just so like kind of
not just like right and there's a bird
on the branch and she goes look Theo
look how beautiful right and like I like
I wish my perception of the world was
like how beautiful right look at this
bird in our home right like look how
cool wow honestly I feel like I just
learned a lot from that story right
there yeah I mean seeing the good you
got to see the good and everything yeah
she had the good going on
um
so what else can I ask you about I mean
obviously you're with your career
growing it's quickly it's crazy how
quick you can get to places where you're
like okay I could maybe work with Miley
Cyrus or I could maybe work with Dolly
Parton like it's probably like it's kind
of like it's crazy wild it is wild and
mandolin and I I mean we've been working
together which is my manager for
everybody listening
um we've been working together for
eight years
oh my gosh we have yeah and um I mean
she was setting me up co-writes and
stuff when I mean nobody would give me
the time of day she's like y'all gotta
listen to her and everybody's like oh no
sorry but um we have we've been like I
mean we're best friends we work very
closely together and we've dreamed up a
lot of these things I mean everything we
put on our list for last year we've
accomplished that and then then some so
we were talking the other day it's
really cool to be able to to dream a
little bit bigger it's like my gosh like
it's really not that far-fetched I mean
we got on a tour bus last June I've been
traveling in a flatbed truck for 10
years you know and
that seemed far-fetched and now here we
are I mean the wheels are turning and
um we gonna do it we're going to
accomplish everything on our list this
year wow yeah I love that I don't even
think we've made a list but we're gonna
make a list she's made the list well
it's scary yeah she probably has that's
good it's scary like yeah making a list
and realizing you can actually like when
you start to achieve some of your dreams
it's kind of scary kind of it is and
I'll say you know
I will I think I'm prepared for what's
going on but there's absolutely another
level of pressure
to look good sound good be good be on be
prepared for everything yeah be fancy
enough yeah yeah I mean the right way
but some of that I think is also a trap
I think especially I feel like with
country music I feel like people come
there because they want I love stories
right and so that's why I think I love a
lot of country and singer songwriter
stuff is because I want to know the
start I just want to hear the story a
lot of times you know that's right
um so I feel like it's at least a genre
where and a universe where you can be a
little bit more you can normal yeah you
don't have to look like you got it all
together yeah I don't I'll tell you that
I do not and yeah the less you have it
together the better I mean look at
Morgan's an example right you know what
I'm saying Morgan is like he's a
relatable one yeah he stays I mean hell
he lived he lived in like a like a dupe
I was like how do you live here like you
can't yeah you're too popular to live
here yeah right yeah but um he tries to
stay as relatable as possible yeah he
does a good job with that a lot of those
guys do now you know already John
party's kind of the same way he's out
there feeding his animals I know turn
around I think you got to do things like
that to I mean if we're gonna write
about it we got to do it yeah I've had
some experience with it I think you know
that's right but that gets scary as your
life gets bigger and busier it's like
you don't have some of those same exact
moments you know for sure
um I did just buy me some land here
around Nashville that I'm excited to you
know kind of get back to some of that
because
when I first got here I mean
you just can't afford to to have animals
and you can't afford to oh yeah it's
expensive
yeah having an animal
yeah I'm trying to think of what kind of
animal you would get and we'll get me
some horses you do I grew up on a horse
and can you be on a horse easily oh yeah
oh really oh yeah
I definitely I mean we rodeoed a little
bit me and my sister we were PRCA Rodeo
flag girls oh what is it that big old
bullet State isn't a saddle you know
what I'm talking about really
not as your sister pretty cheap though
oh she's pretty cheeked up it ain't as
far out but it's definitely as far this
way okay okay yeah I like yeah yeah yeah
so she ain't going nowhere in the saddle
either she got that J in the tray baby
yep and her name is Jana so is it yeah
Janna Janna and does she have a couple
children or not she does oh yeah she got
two little boys Knox and Ledger oh wow
and they are bad yeah they're cute but
they're bad they live in Louisiana they
live in Louisiana God they sound like
damn train robbers they probably will be
I know they probably will be not I love
them to death and they um they got to
come to a show I was doing with Luke
Combs out in Oklahoma city that was the
first show that the boys got to see I
think they were like they had a little
bit of an idea what Aunt Wayne he does
but not really until they got to see it
and I think they were a little bit like
oh okay and now there's dancing around
the house singing in the broomsticks and
yeah like uh oh maybe they got bit by
the bug that's how it starts I think you
know you have to be influenced by
something something kind of has to like
like physically connect you to things
sometimes to know it even exists yep I
remember the first time that I saw a
comedy I didn't know comedy really
existed I mean I'd seen it on television
and stuff but that wasn't enough for me
to really get an idea of it yeah and
then somebody took me to a comedy show
in college and I was like oh my God yeah
like this is a real thing I was watching
this guy
and I was like this is a real thing that
people do wow you know
did you guys have like a big Festival in
y'all's Town to what did because in
Louisiana like I've known for the
festival
for everything yeah I mean literally I I
went down to uh went down over wherever
you want I want to say it's at uh we did
the Rose Bowl Parade in L.A and I got to
be um I got to be on the Louisiana float
and represent Louisiana you did so and
there were lots of queens and I mean
there was the Crawfish Queen there was a
catfish Queen there was a frog Queen
Turtle Queen duck Queen Locust frog I
mean yeah Queens everywhere but baby
yeah raccoon you're like the raccoon
yeah I'm like okay that's all right it's
just some guy up there like with a this
like with us with one of those tank top
sunburns on you like that's my uh one of
my favorite stories about my sister is
she was she was trying to do a pageant
for the um what was it the Watermelon
Festival and she gets out there and
she's you know trying to change her
accent and stuff and she's like
I'm Jana Wilson concasket Kent number
three and then she goes [__] in the
microphone
concasket
she didn't win she didn't win but we had
the catfish Festival was in Winnsboro
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy you know you're under
pressure sometimes you just if she says
[__] I'd give her a 10. yeah yeah you
should have been the judge because I
think they were like no she ain't no
Queen
concussion she was in another pageant
too
um it was like junior miss or something
and they were like what does what does
going green mean to you and she goes
don't pollute
and then walks up she didn't win that
one either
she didn't win that one either
I won Franklin Parish Farm Bureau Queen
did you
I mean yeah that was just like the thing
you're just like
I did I really am I mean I bet but there
was some but there's a couple couple
broads that lost that are still a little
bit Teo they probably are yeah no you
probably are my question was like
you know what is agriculture mean to you
or something like that and I think the
line that like really got him was I was
like agriculture is the backbone of
America and then they were like oh yeah
we're giving her the crown
dude I lost a spelling bee in fifth
grade I'm not even joking to a girl
who after who was who was the same year
got pregnant and was and quit school
really yeah she was older so she wasn't
you know fifth grade she was probably
eighth grade age what was the uh word
that you didn't know her name was Helena
I remember and I couldn't do uh
inconvenience well I wouldn't be able to
do that anyway either I'm like I
couldn't handle it ma'am I couldn't
handle that pressure
my god dude I still feel every time it
comes up I just it just takes you back
God yeah and then I started thinking
about her and her child every time I
hear that word I need to go down rabbit
holes I know yeah it's really
inconvenient so yeah so it gets a little
wild
um that was funny I'm going to uh
Louisiana this week actually I got shows
in Shreveport in Baton Rouge you gonna
get you some crawfish maybe some oysters
I guess okay
apparently a neighbor is we're in Gaza I
think we're like literally in Baghdad I
feel like something going on over there
only two times have we ever had like
real issues here in this with when jelly
roll was here well and then today I saw
jelly roll last night you did I must be
bringing in the juju
I love jelly I just I worry about his
health though did he look pretty good he
looked good he looked like he was
feeling good I mean he yeah he's he's
one of my favorites we're on the same
label oh y'all are yep he said the
reason he knew he wanted to be a part of
that life he said because I I got on the
website and I looked to see you know the
roster he said I saw Laney's Old redneck
hippie ass weren't trying to wear bell
bottom stuff and then I saw you know
Jimmy Allen and then I saw uh Frank Ray
he's a ex Mexican cop and then I saw
um who else was it he said it just
looked like a halfway house he said and
I said this is the place for me
I'm like perfect I'll take that he's the
best man a bunch of Misfits people love
him he's so I mean there ain't nobody
like him nope he is just him
yeah he's like a uh yeah there's nobody
like him and just as his stories
yeah and you you get you wanna and you
love him like the music obviously is
great and he's had a yes even had a
number one I mean how far did his son of
a center go it's so good it did go
number one
it's so good
yep so um
but yeah there's just something about
him and he's got so many great stories
he just just everything about him I know
it's like even if the music wasn't good
you'd still want to root for him but
it's just a plus that the music is good
right
um
yeah I think there's just yeah you just
love him so much I think that's that's
the there's I feel like there's two
types of artists in in almost any genre
I think you're or in any
like template of art you're either like
people are there for you or they're
there for the art that's right and
sometimes it's both and sometimes yeah
you're right but some guys it's like you
get are you or your reason you get into
them is one or the other yeah I know I
mean it's just Yeah because sometimes
it's like I like the person so much I
almost don't care what they make I agree
I mean I got some buddies so I'm like oh
that is but I love you
but I love you
um yeah but I'm gonna get some oysters
actually so I'm excited about that I
think
but oysters are so weird oysters are
like I think they're supposed to not be
eaten
uh here's the thing for me it like
depends on the day and I'm kind of the
same way with sushi too it just depends
on the day whether I can actually do
them raw or not yeah
um I will say if you haven't been in
Hendersonville there's a place called
Moby Dickies it's on the water and I
wouldn't normally like eat oysters
around here but um they have some really
good but why wouldn't you eat them
around here I don't know I mean I just
feel like eating them in south Louisiana
is probably a little bit better that's
true yeah it seemed like they how they
get up here you know did they Uber yeah
I think they opened all right they might
have left they use lips for sure yeah
oysters yeah they definitely because
oysters aren't supposed to be eaten
first of all who would eat if you
I can't imagine
but you'd have to be I feel like some
type of pedophile or something to open
something that small and put your dang
tongue in no you're right it's a little
bit
it's a little bit weird yeah I think we
all might be a little weird it's a
little I mean it's like because it's
just so small I just I don't know every
time I open them I feel bad but I tell
you what I feel like I'm from Louisiana
every time I do it I'm like I'm doing
this because I'm from Louisiana you know
yeah crawfish though I mean I could I'll
make a special trip home just to go get
me some crawfish yeah
yeah but that always every time I open
it I feel like it's parents aren't home
you know yeah yeah yeah I just feel like
sneaky I just feel bad just nasty I mean
like I don't want to say it's nasty I
feel a little bit like a creep kind of
um
so you got into some acting right yep uh
how has that been like and what was it
like because also the main character in
um oh no not Yellowstone I'm thinking of
that show 1942 Have You Seen Her 1732
what is it called 16 oh there's a you
don't talk about yeah yeah there's
several of them 1922 23 1923.
the first time you met jelly roll was
your first acting gig really oh it's
true yeah let's talk about that real
quick okay the first time you met jelly
roll
um and mandolin is her manager she's
here and she just said the first time
she met jelly roll was uh you guys acted
together no I was pretty much an extra
in a music video that he was doing with
Uncle Kracker no and they told me
earlier that day
um they were like we'll pay you a
hundred dollars if you come out here for
the day and act like a drunk person
passed out on the ground I did it and I
never got my hundred dollars yeah I
don't even know if I've told jelly that
I didn't get my hundred dollars dude I'm
gonna tell him he better venomy
but uh Uncle Kracker passed away didn't
he I don't City
I don't know I don't think he did he
might have people don't know
[Laughter]
I feel like he's one of those people
that just could have passed away you
don't know you know
yep yep yep yeah I don't know everybody
I feel like who spent time with Kid Rock
ends up dying so I better not hang out
with him then
no I'm joking I love Bob Bob is a nice
guy
um
but okay so tell me about so oh no but
the man I'm thinking of is from
Louisiana he's an actor on that show
1940 us uh
um uh
Faith uh talking about Tim McGraw Tim
McGraw oh 1883 you're talking about okay
okay sorry I thought you were talking
about 19 something and thank you yeah
Tim McGraw he's actually uh from like
start Louisiana but
um I had some grandparents that lived in
ward 3 Louisiana and he got brought home
from the hospital to like a little house
that was in ward 3 and my step
grandmother used to babysit him really
I've never met Tim either wow but we
know a lot of the same people I've been
here that's a town Ward three yeah you
know some small towns we had wow so your
grandmother used to babysit him my step
grandma and what did she say about him
anything I mean he was like a tiny tiny
baby like but still you can I think even
look at an a baby she said I knew he was
a star and is this it right here let me
see Third Ward no that's Third Ward of
New Orleans dude yeah yeah yeah Ward
three it's just like yeah the third word
I think is that's where Little Wayne is
Ward 3 Louisiana who knows it's even
like an actual official name of a town
but that's what they call it wow it's
like Provo Louisiana and then right
outside of it is Ward three
dude I met a girl one time we had like
the student council thing and like all
the rappers it was at our school in high
school right and so I think I was on the
student council I don't even know what I
was doing but I was there and they had
like all these kids came from other
places and I met some girl from rain
Louisiana where is that I don't know I'd
never heard of it right but I was like
oh my God sounds pretty magical you are
beautiful I remember right and I just
wrote a big piece of poster board and
said you are beautiful no you did not I
did and I gave it to her I gave it to
her as you're sitting there opening up
an oyster
yeah you're beautiful I got a warm
oyster for you oh but I remember yeah
and she said you should come to the Frog
Festival something oh and I was like I'm
in I'll start jumping to get there
because it was far away they it was like
kind of it was farther than it was far
away and
and uh I never I think we called each
other one time at night and that was it
that was it I remember I used to write
down things on a notepad of what to talk
about when I was like talking on the
phone in high school or Junior High
whatever it was I'd be like ask him if
he caught any frogs when he was frog ask
him how many frogs did he gig ask him
did he have fun
I'm like do you not know how to have a
conversation
Lord
but sometimes you don't I think
sometimes you don't know how to have a
conversation especially when you're
young and you're like talking to the
opposite sex and that's right mom would
get on and she would always be like you
need to go clean something and it would
always be like what when you were just
getting to the good part oh there was
never a good part but I was just being
alive on the phone with a woman I know
and then oh she always ruined it every
time I remember being so nervous yeah it
was crazy like why
because I think it's just your first
time doing it like you can't even
replicate those nerves as you get it's
like I mean you're you're like hard you
don't even know what's going on yeah
you're like embarrassed also you're it
is it's embarrassing yes
you're almost embarrassed of who you are
like how uncomfortable you are yes
that's very embarrassing
I remember that
like who am I I don't know how am I dude
what do I do I know and then seeing a
girl at school like or that was always
weird and then you like had to sing
between class so you like and you like
don't know if you need to make eye
contact going down the hall yeah and you
just scream like I love you
yeah you're like what oh yeah do you
know uh how much your subscriptions cost
do you know most Americans think they
spend around eighty dollars a month on
subscriptions when the actual total is
closer to 200 dang
if you don't know exactly how much
you're spending every month you need
rocket money
that's right rocket money formerly known
as true bill is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place
over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about you
might have a one new uh butcher baby or
one to um asthma club or something and
they're mailing your lungs or whatever
well rocket money will quickly and
easily identify your subscriptions for
you so you can stop paying for the ones
you don't want that's it
I've used rocket money I like it it
helped me figure out that I had uh two
accounts
um on one of my streaming services I
didn't know and I'm losing cash
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com Theo that's
rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o rocketmoney.com Theo guys it's
all about confidence I don't have it but
somebody might
sometimes you gotta get you want to get
that confidence in that shank baby and
that body shank you know what I'm
talking about that wiener baby
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
if you're paying big dollar for those
deals get on get over to Bluetooth and
learn about it
and now
they also have Varden Apple mint
flavored chew apples baby
with the active ingredient in Levitra
and staxon
she can stay hard and fresh maybe keep
that shank fresh
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and it's
all done online it's discreet baby
nobody knows you getting them uppers
that's it and guys here's a special deal
for you try blue chew free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month free
there was Valentine's Day I was in
seventh grade I believe I just switched
schools and um this boy I don't know if
I don't know if he had a crush on me but
this ain't the way to let me know if it
did but it was Valentine's Day and he
goes
Lainey Wilson
uh you know everybody kind of turns
around and he goes roses are red violets
are black why is your chest as flat as
your back
and I was like yep that's honestly
pretty good I'm gonna write that one
down I couldn't help you know being a
songwriter I was like that's pretty good
you're like that's copyright that's it
yeah
shouting stuff down the halls I remember
those days oh yeah and I would always
lie to my friends and I would say that I
had a girlfriend that lived in another
town and
I remember doing that and then my first
girlfriend she played softball and she
was strong God she was strong whoop that
butt and I think she was a woman you
know and she I remember the bus would
come by she would pick me up
and like kiss me when the bus pick you
up yeah she was strong and literally I
wonder where she's at nowadays oh I'm
sure she is uh you think she's coaching
I don't know oh yeah you should look her
up she's coaching some man
um yeah yeah she wolfing somebody but
yeah she's yeah yeah this kid she could
be doing chocolate body contest who
knows that's her but she remember and I
remember she would even wrap my legs
around her waist she was like a she was
and he loved it I didn't have I was
scared
I was scared man and then the worst part
was the bus would be there and my
brother and his friends
and they would yell stuff at us out of
the box
when you were just sitting there and
just own her like a baby had you on her
hip I didn't want to be I just yeah I
just didn't have any other choice she
was so strong yeah she played second
base and mid middle feet and just
Outfield yeah God she was strong drove
I'm like how do you drive like we don't
even yeah but she was just so strong me
and my sister used to drive to school
when we were wow
oh yeah it was such a big adventure
wasn't it oh it was and we stopped by
the convenience store and basket and get
them crispitos or one of them deep fried
hot pockets and oh they deep-fried a Hot
Pocket yes God they ain't doing that in
south Louisiana I don't think so I feel
like if you went to the gas station it
was a lot more like chicken tenders
and like I remember that like a homemade
root beer somebody did for a while but
it was bad oh and people were getting
sick
it won't stop me from getting it oh yeah
I mean we drank it for months but yeah
but we were sick
people's hair was falling out it was a
bad but it's still good I think it had
like Monsanto in it or something it was
bad it was a bad batch
um what was that article oh a couple
monkeys guy they got uh two monkeys that
been taken from a zoo uh-oh did y'all
have a zoo and Baskin no we did a Monroe
and did y'all have an animal padding
facility because we didn't have a zoo
but we had an animal petting facility
that was nearby where you could go and
pet them you know things I ended up
getting one of those after I had already
gone not in Winnsboro but kind of like
on outskirts kind of like a little
Safari like Drive Through Safari thing
yeah
um it's like a petting zoo kind of yeah
which I've never been you never been to
a petting zoo no
I feel like my house was a little bit of
a petting zoo
really but I mean I mean we had horses
and
um a lot of like family members and
stuff would have other
goats and sheep and you'll have like a
cook shed in the back and stuff did you
guys like
um
because some people have that in
Louisiana they have like a cook shed you
know I mean there we would honestly we'd
go to the Tractor shed at my Granny's
house and we'd um yeah that's they would
fry up some stuff I feel like somebody
was always cooking something yeah you
know yeah it's popular
people like to grill cook and kill
something and then just cook it yep did
your uh or your grandparents still marry
or your are your parents still married
yep oh wow they are they are they've
been married
36 years oh dang I believe yep my mom
and daddy met she was 19 years old and
no they got married when she was 19. I
think she met him when she was like 17
or something like that yeah he was going
to college and
yep he swept her right off her feet they
crazy made a good kind of crazy but they
crazy
um yeah I remember like in even in like
Junior High they'd have like older men
or like guys would come and like bring
like
McDonald's to like the girls at our
school wouldn't put it over the fence
and that was I know I'm like I'm falling
in love for real that's like Dude get me
a McMuffin that's all that's it the
second we saw like a girl from our
school walk over to the fence to get
fast food from an adult
we knew we lost her
she gone oh
my God I just remember because you'd see
the car pull up and you'd see him get
out you know you'd hear his boots
hitting around like I can't do that like
I can't offer her that oh I have nothing
you know it's over yeah I'm over here
yeah just having me a little handful of
runts that I bombed off a buddy and
she's over there and then she'd Wahoo
whoever it was and walk out like God no
they got Amber I think she kind of
showing it off a little bit you know
like everybody's like how did you get
that yeah
it was just the biggest deal yeah God if
you had food from somewhere else at
lunch it was cool
you were like a son you were like
someone that had gone to outer space
truly and everybody's looking at you
like you're the center of attention for
the meal it was good stuff yeah
um that is so true it was just like yeah
it was just little things like that man
do you remember
um the first date that you ever went on
like where you went on an actual date
yep
um went Red Lobster I ate some of them
cheesy have you had the cheesy biscuits
from cheesy biscuits yes someone killed
their spouse over a batch of them can
you look that up well I can understand
why
I mean
but really are you you're for real that
really happened oh yeah oh you can
Google someone killed spouse over any
food and there's something
now that's crazy
keep looking
so y'all went there and what was it did
the guy pick you up oh no we were like
real young it was like we went
this is the guy that I dated pretty much
my whole life he was like my childhood
sweetheart so it's like his parents were
sitting at another little booth kind of
like watching us
um but I remember he ordered
crab legs and I remember he he like was
he a damn mayor
oh
he cracked it and a piece of crab flew
right in my hair and I was so
embarrassed I was mortified I was over
there just enjoying my cheesy biscuit
and that dang crab landed in my hair and
I'm like oh he's and I don't know why
but at 13 years old or however old I was
I was like oh he's not gonna like me
anymore even though he did it to me and
suddenly that's like catching the
bouquet at a wedding you're right you're
right if you get a piece of crab stuck
in your hair yeah that is dang good luck
I know I think you're right I didn't
know to appreciate it then but I do now
that's hot magic yep so that was my
first date
and I think we got that um
yes they have like this big old
chocolate chip cookie Skillet yeah
yeah now that right there I could just
eat that for my meal oh yeah
well some places you know in the midwest
they'll have pie first they'll be like
you want your pie first really or dinner
so you don't so to make sure you have
room for it
it's real common you walk into like a
lot of diners there and said you want
your pie first wow
and I get it I mean I'd rather have the
pie too but yeah
but to say for yeah but I it's just
interesting I sing that over there
um but speaking of like like real
official dates and stuff I did not have
like a real official date until a few
years ago when when somebody actually
mandolin manager she was setting up my
dates too we're sitting on my co-wright
setting up my dates she literally told
her friend from school she was like
Laney has never been on like an official
like you know somebody asked you to go
somewhere like like a first date right
like an official date because it's
always been like I hung out with a dude
or whatever and then we would go get
some food yeah but it was nice he showed
me what it was supposed to be like and
and did he pick you up
when you meet him there I met him there
okay because it was a first date yeah I
met him that's kind of that makes sense
Kinda Yeah I met him there but it was he
was a gentleman and did he
um and did y'all did he um open the door
oh yeah like he walked me to my car and
then then we went and kind of it was one
of those things where we knew neither
one of us we weren't going to date he
was kind of just doing me a favor okay
okay he's like I'm gonna take this girl
out like he knows that I was just too
much for him I mean really oh really
yeah I mean he's just wow what happened
I mean was he small no no no no not
small but like I'm just I'm pretty sassy
are you and spicy yeah I can't help it
really it's just that Louisiana thing
yeah I mean you know were you violent
too or no no okay no he fed me good oh
that's good yeah you gotta sedate him a
little bit we knew like after we hung
out I was like yeah we'll be friends
it'll be you know when we see each other
we'll catch back up and a good boy who
showed me what it was supposed to be
like oh he showed me that like yeah it's
it's okay to still be traditional I like
being traditional you do yeah I do yeah
I like tradition I think I like a lot of
traditions in uh in our country I think
you know I just think tradition is good
stuff I I think it's like it's nice to
have like patterns and stuff you know I
agree
I mean at the end of the day like I can
I can tend to myself and and take care
of you know like I don't need somebody
to open up a door for me whatever but
every now and then it's nice to feel
like yeah that's that's very nice yeah I
got it for you yeah yeah um do you
remember the first time you ever had a
kiss do you remember it yep I had braces
oh we went in kissed somebody with
braces on me
oh yeah that's pretty sick I was pretty
sick bro hey bro yeah but oh if I'm
kissing somebody with braces on bro take
me to jail yeah yeah yeah
we were out in a little shop they were
like and what do you mean there's like
machines and stuff like Hammers and you
know wrenches and stuff hanging a while
I was at my friend Katie's house and her
boyfriend had just left and I thought
tonight's the night I'm I'm going in and
you planned it well I knew it was
happening okay I could just tell how he
was acting like he gonna try to kiss me
tonight so I need to be prepared
but I was a little too prepared because
when I tell you I just opened my mouth
up wide and did this me too
I literally was like trying to eat his
face or something I don't know what like
what made me think that I needed to just
do this
[Laughter]
that ain't how it goes it took me a
minute
but it didn't run him off
he liked it well yeah look if some chick
comes at me with an open mouth I think
I'm gonna figure it out you know but you
would terrify me oh that was that's
spooky that happened to me I was playing
we played spin the bottle in this girl I
loved oh my God and he messed that up
with that kiss
I'm like there's no way she might really
like me and it was like yeah I had the
chance to kiss her and I was like I
remember like leaning forward into the
group and I couldn't even feel my arms
they were like they felt like they
belonged to somebody else and somebody
like who was like like somebody I didn't
even trust it was oh yeah you were just
like rattling dude and I felt like you
could hear my freaking bones rambling
and I'm like oh my God and then I just
and he went in my mouth I'd seen that on
TV I think like open mouth yeah yeah
and everybody was laughing and then I
remember I almost like
I didn't go in like a closet or anything
to no I'm just gonna do it right out
there and that's that's terrible they
shouldn't have done you dirty like that
God it was horrible man and then I knew
I felt like a fish trying to eat
something and then I felt so sad and
then I remember thinking oh man that's
it
that's it you know and then I saw this
other real creepy dude later that night
brushing that girl's hair by the fire
and I'm like at least I'm not that dead
yeah no that's
yeah that guy's a real creep uh-huh I
wonder what he's doing now I don't know
I could imagine time
yep
um what uh so tell me about acting some
so I know some about your career right
and I know General stuff but
um and I know some specifics but I like
to just yeah you know see what you think
about stuff so was that scary was it
like I mean obviously it's exciting
because Yellowstone's a big show yeah
but was it
would you think of that it's a big time
commitment with that for sure it is so
Yellowstone I mean they've been great to
me they put several of my songs on the
show which really just introduced me to
a crowd of people who might not listen
to radio or strain music I mean I have
people still you know come to the shows
and they're like before your acting gig
like I found your music through
Yellowstone so it's crazy to think that
a Show's soundtrack is really like that
helpful but for Yellowstone it is it
truly is and
Taylor Sheridan
um the writer and producer he's just
been good to me I mean he called me last
February and he's like
he said I got this idea he said I want
to create a character specifically for
you and he said wear your bell bottoms
sing your songs pretty much be you but
um go buy a musician named Abby
and I mean this is my first acting gig
I've been acting to fool my whole life
but this was like you know the real
thing and this was like a a huge thing
concerning it was my first too
um but I had so much fun I didn't know
what to expect I will say there are a
lot of similarities like with what I
normally do on a on a daily basis and
that I mean like it's a lot of hurry up
and wait you get ready for the scene you
you're waiting for your you know your
moment to shine and you got like a few
minutes to show them what you can do you
know or even when it comes to like
learning the lines it's like learning a
song that I didn't write
um but everybody made me feel so
comfortable I mean I became great
friends with a lot of them Beth I mean
she is Kelly Riley she is so badass and
she's actually really kind uh when when
we first met because my very first scene
was with her
bring her up there buddy Kelly Riley
bring her up on there Kelly Riley you
know she's British oh yeah I know about
him yep she British so you should have
heard mine in her conversation we needed
a dank translator
yeah
but she's great she's still you can tell
that she's still got that Spitfire
Spirit about her
um but she is a a good human I mean she
made me buy assaults and oh dang I was
like okay I thought you gonna put me in
a headlock you making me bath salts bath
salts are
people die from them
yeah well we're gonna do the right thing
with the bath salts
I'm gonna call her yeah man that's
swimmer's myth
it but I [__] that's some hardcore stuff
um
wow so but tell me your first scene when
you got to get out there and do it
because that's when it's scary when
they're like
at when the when you know when they say
action and it's on like you got to get
that line out and your brain is like
listening to you say it yeah it's like
you get stuck in that space kind of I
mean what was any of that like was it
I'll tell you I was I was real nervous
um that day but
I have I had a lot of family members
praying for me that day for me to not be
nervous and for me to just kind of be in
my body and people were sending me Good
Vibes and
um I really think that helped because
when I got out there to do it for some
crazy reason I was not nervous at all
it was like I have been doing it my
whole life
and I'm like
kind of freaked out that I wasn't
nervous you know wow I was nervous for
the kissing scene my first kissing scene
oh y'all were kissing on there dude
yes I said I'm gonna be on the name
church prayer list back at home
I didn't know what to expect with all
that either I'm like and who was the man
um he goes by Ryan on the show his name
is Ian Bowen he's become a dear friend
of mine too he's actually one of my
biggest Champions I mean he just he
shows up to shows he knows all the words
to my songs better than I do well heck
you kissed him I'd freaking Polly follow
you yeah yeah he's following me
um bring up that man if we can huh
and Bowen Ian Bowen and he's out there
lip locking out there that's right and
it wasn't his first rodeo dang he's
handsome huh I mean he's all right I
mean all the Cowboys on that show they
yeah it's a real it's a lot of
handsomers on there huh a lot of
handsomers because I've seen the other
one I haven't seen this show yep
I know the some of the chaos but I've
not seen this show but yeah he looks
like a handsome guy
oh look at that huh oh yeah I mean we
got down to it that was the first our
first little interaction and
so did you guys talk before it yeah huh
yeah we did we uh we actually had a a
few days of working together before we
actually had to you know
do the do the thing
um but
yeah we just got to know each other and
I mean I did like I said I didn't know I
didn't know if like we really needed to
go in or like go in or whatever I mean
y'all made on there too or is just
kissing it's just kissing
I mean I wake up in a tent in one scene
um so it's kind of up to your
imagination oh damn but you know that's
that's as as risque as it got well my
imagination uh it has yeah yeah it's
it is not allowed around me anymore
uh-huh put that thing away oh yeah yeah
better take the batteries out of that
thing that's right
um wow that's so wild so isn't it isn't
it interestingly to feel like your
dreams coming true what is that kind of
like oh you're ever able to get in any
moments like that because that's kind of
interesting like
you know a lot so many people have
dreams in the world and it's hard to you
know not all of us get to have them come
true it's that is very true I feel very
lucky I feel like
we talk about this all the time but it
seems like the stars have to align over
and over and over and over again and
they gotta align again you know and I
mean you can work hard and keep your
head down and and do your thing or
whatever but it's still it's Gotta Have
a little bit to do with luck too
um
I feel I feel like I've been because
I've been here for so long and working
at this ever since I was nine years old
I'm 30 years old you know I feel like
I've been like preparing for the race
like I finally entered it and just now
I'm about to run it I mean it feels like
it's just beginning now so I don't think
I haven't had a moment where I'm like oh
I've made it
I feel like we're doing it you know I
feel like things are coming to fruition
but I also feel like there's a lot more
[__] to be done
yeah it's really interesting yeah it's
almost like when you've because there's
times there's times when you're going
through your career you're like I should
be having this opportunity right yeah
but then you realize later that if you'd
have gotten those opportunities at that
point you wouldn't have even been ready
nope you're right I'm glad it's taking
me a long time I mean and not that long
you look lovely by the way and I don't
think you look
probably 20. ah I like you or 20 and a
half maybe oh okay I'll take it or 22.
sorry and I'll keep going until we get
you know until everything seems okay
no
I will say for the longest time people
made me feel like like don't talk about
your age in this town yeah it's going to
date you you know but at the end of the
day I'm I'm proud to be 30 I'm proud you
know that it has taken me this long
because I feel like time is a part of my
story and I feel like it's I don't know
you know I wanna I wanna show little
girls and boys that
sometimes it's going to take you a
little longer than some folks I mean I
moved to this town and people were
passing me up left and right getting
publishing deals getting record deals
and
at the end of the day sometimes slow and
steady you know is better and I feel
like I've been trying to do Brick by
Brick just one thing at a time because I
want longevity I don't want to just be a
flash in the pan and I'm not I'm not
doing that so you couldn't be I don't
think
um
I don't see how it would even be
possible and it's funny because if I
listen to Heart Like a truck right but
you're 24 years old I it's not it I
don't believe that yep no I've been
through some stuff
yep and I'm proud of it it's been hard I
mean there's definitely times where I
wish it wouldn't have been that way I
mean
I mean even it's weird because like I
I'm experiencing like really great
things with my career right now even
when I was filming Yellowstone I was
going through like we were losing my
daddy
um he ended up Surviving but like he was
spent two months in ICU and I was having
to actually a few of those scenes right
there
um I would go over to the corner and cry
and then come back and then shoot it
again and
it just seems sometimes I'm like man
am I supposed to go through these things
so I can be more relatable to people and
and be more understanding and be able to
write the kind of music that people are
really gonna connect to and listen to
and that's kind of what I chalk it up to
sometimes because I mean life ain't easy
yeah it is what it is you just gotta
keep rolling yeah and sometimes it's
like I don't know I feel like sometimes
like God has a way of reaching people
right and not to make it religious or
anything but it's like sometimes you're
just part of that way that's right you
know and it's not even
yet you have talents and stuff but it's
like sometimes some things they're so
especially with music it's like man this
thing is and so many people have written
and you know there's other people
playing and it's like really to make
this thing it's like it takes a a
village it does take a village you know
I like the best way for me to explain it
to people who ask about the industry I
just say it's like the artist is like at
the center of the wheel and there's a
million different spokes I mean you got
your label you got your management you
got your business manager you got your
tour manager you got your bands you got
publicity you got publishing so many
different spokes of the wheel and all of
them have to be turning
fluid you know they all have to be
lining up and if one little thing is off
you in a ditch yeah you're in a ditch
you're on a unicycle in a dang ditch
that is it yeah that is that's the best
way to explain it the crab in your hair
boom
um what happened with your father he was
sick yes it was actually a fungal
infection oh dang that um kind of took
out the left side of the inside of his
face so anything that this fungus
touched just it turned to dirt it's like
the most like aggressive type of fungus
there is how do you get it
um I mean it could have been from the
farm it could have been from the barn
anything like that super rare super rare
and he's actually the
with the people who were kind of like
leading the case and stuff he's a second
person to ever survive it that they've
worked with and with few of the doctors
he's the first one to ever survive it
but he had nine surgeries in a month and
a half they kept going in to remove the
fungus and then he had a stroke on top
of all that so oh man that must have
been heartbreaking it it was and it's he
still got a little ways to go but
actually
this this past week a big old praise
report he went back to work several like
just for like a couple hours just to go
up there and kind of [__] with some
of his friends but that right there
that's work in Louisiana that's work and
that's also just that's a big old step
so wow I must have been that must have
felt awesome for him yep I'm ready for
him to be able to I mean he's still
driving the tractor and he's doing stuff
like that but
ready for him to start having some more
interactions with people because I think
just interacting with with people is
healing in general yeah you've healed me
today
[Music]
oh thanks back at you yeah I've just
felt so off my I don't even know what's
going on today I get it you do I get it
I'm moving right now
no I trust me for me it's like
it's just like that Mojo that that you
find right before you go on stage
sometimes it's hard to find that like
impossible
impossible yeah
is it is are there are there shows and
obviously I'm sure all your shows are
great are there shows and moments where
it's like
or there's some shows where for some
reason you're eight you're able to hit
another gear I find that without me I
don't know if it's like that with music
at all oh it absolutely is
um I feed off the crowd
and you probably do the same exact thing
I feel like it's like an energy exchange
like if their energy is up here yeah
that's where I'm at if they're energy is
down here that's that's kind of where
I'm at too
um I mean one little thing can throw the
show all off like the other night I had
somebody spit at me yeah yeah I'm like
why are you gonna pay for a ticket then
spit at me like I ain't trying to fight
nobody tonight and I had that in my
brain the whole night you know yeah and
then it kind of you then go down rabbit
holes why are they spitting at me yeah
you see somebody just spitting like dip
and you're like [__] him you just start
losing somebody is that's him right
there get him out some guy's drooling
some guys like he has like a Bell's
palsy but yeah yeah yeah that's him he
did it yeah oh we had a show the other
night some girl was just what and
usually for comedy you want people to be
quiet yeah so oddly it's kind of the
opposite you want it to be silenced
because you'll use the silence to kind
of create the next moment for the yeah
yeah you know so you want them to laugh
when they're you know when it's funny
but you want them to otherwise kind of
and people want to yell out stuff you
know and just yell out cocaine yeah no
[__] sometimes you know everybody on the
crowd saying Free Bird yeah and I'm like
the amount of times I've heard that
yeah so yeah it's like the other night
the show is just it threw everything off
so much in the beginning that it was
just kind of a bad show I felt like you
know I know I get that it happened and
it's hard to kind of come back from it
yeah it's hard about yeah sometimes it's
hard to bounce back it's just
and sometimes you just gotta chalk it up
to that's just how the night went the
crowd someone doesn't even know I know
yeah they have no clue because there's
times where I'll get off stage and I'll
tell my band like oh my gosh I was like
struggling tonight I could not find that
that thing or I was like I was searching
for that certain feeling you know yeah
and um and I didn't get that feeling so
therefore I feel like I like let myself
down or let everybody else down and the
band was like oh my gosh to me that was
one of the best shows that we played yet
and I'm like is something wrong with me
yeah and then there's times where
they're like I did terrible tonight and
I'm like that's the best show we've ever
played because of that feeling yeah
that's exactly what it is I'm looking
it's almost selfish man I'm looking for
some feeling that I think that that I
usually get when the show feels good to
me yes and they might not have any clue
no they're they're thinking that is the
best thing I've ever seen yeah that is
the funniest thing I've ever seen
it's interesting we had a yeah usually
it's a woman that gets crazy at a comedy
show sometimes it's like a a lot of
times it's a woman that'll get
outrageous kind of like a drunk woman or
something yeah yeah a real drunk lady
he'll get drunk how do you deal with
that we end up usually tossing them out
yeah yeah because then it just
satisfactions
and he's like you know
muffin never gets drunk and I'm like
well first of all muffin gets drunk
that's right and muffin is drunk tonight
muffin gotta go yeah yeah
we need to put muffin in the damn to-go
box I want a meat muffin though she does
sound like a good time
um
um I'm trying to think of what else I
mean obviously your career just really
speaks for itself you know I'm uh I'm
grateful that we get to sit and chat a
little bit anything band that you wanted
to bring up
for you do you have little pieces of the
puzzle that help you start writing a
song or finish a song like what do you
tell those writers listening to you
right now yeah I like that
what is it
what did he say and that is a big old
question you're gonna have to repeat it
again because I barely know okay
basically like no here's the the easy
version
um what is like my songwriting process
like because it's probably pretty dang
similar to like the way that you write
you know
um for me the cool thing about
songwriting is it's different every
single time I sit down I mean I feel
like some people you know they start
with one thing pretty much all the time
but for me it could start with a Melody
it could start with a guitar riff
um but no matter what it always starts
with an idea for me I keep this little
list in my phone called my hook book and
that's where I just you know probably
you probably did the same thing you jot
down that's kind of
seedy women yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so then I'll look through there but at
the end of the day I feel like I've been
given the opportunity to write with so
many incredible writers here in
Nashville that they've kind of taught me
how to put myself into the shoes of
whatever it is that we're writing about
I mean if we wanted to write about this
thing right here you know then they've
kind of taught me how to like feel that
for everything that it is and right from
that perspective which is pretty dang
therapeutic
um oh that's interesting so you find
there's a lot of therapy in it really it
is and sometimes I mean of course a lot
of my songs I have and most of the songs
that I end up cutting are songs that are
super personal to me but there is
something really cool about kind of just
stepping outside of your shoes for a
minute and put your putting yourself
into somebody else's and that is
very freeing
I love it I love song I mean songwriting
was my number one
I mean like I said I wrote my first song
at nine years old and when I moved here
in to Nashville that's that's what's
songwriting was the foot that I led with
yeah I figured that was my strength and
that's the only way that I could you
know maybe get my foot in the door was
through my songwriting so
is it serves a very it's
a special thing in my life
wow that's interesting yeah I used to
love to write music I used to love to
write country songs I used to look yeah
sometimes when I was working on that
tractor I would stop it and I would
stand out on it and listen to like top
40 country and it was like Clay Walker
was
he had this Uncle she's always right and
uh I would like sing that at the top of
my lungs and I used to love to write
country music um
did you uh was there a point where you
thought you would just be a songwriter
um I always knew that
like does that happen in artists like I
just wonder like because sometimes with
comedians right there's you do comedy
and then sometimes you're like oh I'm
just going to be a writer and I'm gonna
write for like a late night show or like
a Fallon or like which you were just on
or like uh you know or I'm gonna write
for a comedian yeah but I don't know if
the dream ever goes away to just do
comedy but sometimes life gets in the
way you'll get a family or something
yeah and things kind of have to shift
I'll say
I didn't want to have to choose I was
like I can do both I'm going to be a
songwriter I'm going to be an artist I'm
gonna do it all but I had somebody who
was who I was working with at the time
who made me believe you can't be both he
was like really you got to choose are
you a songwriter are you an artist and
I'm like I'm both he's like no no but
you gotta like you gotta really and I'm
like no
look around at some of the most
successful artists I mean decades and
deca for decades you know
they write their own stuff and they sing
their own stuff and it doesn't mean that
I'm opposed to you know cutting outside
songs at the end of the day like I said
the best idea and the best song wins
um
but you can do both
look at Morgan look at Hardy look at
look at all the guys and look at Ernest
he's the pitch for Lipscomb that's what
I'm saying like
you can do it you shouldn't being
creative you shouldn't
be scared to step outside of the box and
in my opinion that's not even really
stepping outside of the box it's just
singing the stuff that you wrote yeah
and he was going to sing it better than
you he was so wrong that really seems to
yeah that amps you up I'm ready to fight
dude I thought yeah you can beat the
[__] out of me if you want I've been I
mean by women I might
put it on on the camera we're gonna do
it afterwards
other people want
look well I'll open a Bible he can beat
the damn devil out of them that's gonna
be hard to do that's gonna take a few
Bibles yeah yeah we're gonna give man a
little bible too we're gonna beat the
[__] out of you
dude Bibles should come with a little
bat when I feel like some of them you
know because some people really need to
be beaten about that's right
um okay so what's coming up then you
just have two you have a lot of touring
I mean how does that end yeah this was
my song she's always right did you ever
hear that song oh God I fell in love
every time I heard this dang song
yeah I used to love that one love it
it's a good one oh Clay Walker
um
all right we'll talk your ears off yeah
it's okay it's been nice thanks for your
patience thank you thank you for having
me this is have fun I knew we get along
you did yeah
yeah I thought I mean I feel like you
get along with everybody but yeah yeah I
don't know a lot of female singers
really yep you know I don't think anyway
I might
you might I can't remember but
um
but anyway
um congratulations on all your success
you'll just be touring a lot then is
that what's going on yep we are doing my
first headlining tour right now called
country with a flare okay we got my
friends May McCree Ben Chapman and Leah
Blevins out with us and
um love them believe in them so much
it's nice to feel like I'm finally able
to like I'm in a position where I could
help somebody else because I had so many
people help me along the way it just
that it feels good to be able to do that
just even inviting them on on the road
you know oh yeah I can help them so
um doing that we are going out with Luke
combs for the stadium tour really which
is a full circle thing for me because he
used to come over to my camper and we'd
write and so we're doing that we've got
I mean so many things exciting things
this year and
um hopefully be filming some more
Yellowstone we'll see dang it's a lot
it's a lot so people can just go well
obviously they can get tickets to the
Luke comb show and then
yeah my tour is completely sold out yeah
we're even moving to some bigger venue
so it's exciting stuff considering
I mean so last year looked different I'm
not gonna lie it's crazy really yeah I
mean I played
Yeah March of last year in Tuscaloosa
um we had had a hit with things a man
ought to know and never say never what
Cole Swindell was
just it was killing it at that time too
I see like there were so many things
that we had done but I still could
barely sell a ticket wow I sold like was
it 100 or like 91 tickets or something
like that
and a lot of people there were family
and it was like where like where is this
not connecting you know like I feel like
we we won some awards we got some number
ones but still at that time I was pretty
faceless I think that's what happens
with a lot of artists so explain that to
me when you say faceless because this
isn't yeah I think a lot of people know
songs on the radio I think during that
time if you would have asked anybody who
listens to country music like you know
that song things a man ought to know
they all would have said yes but they
did not
know me
and that's where the disconnect is and I
think that's really where Yellowstone
has been
so beneficial because
you know they see your name up on the
screen and and stuff and then they
finally just like see your face and
they're like oh okay and then I have to
see it a million other times for it to
really really connect yeah how many
times they say you got a
yeah you have to have like 12 to 15
impressions for people to even like
remember or be like oh that's who that
is let me go check it out dang because
there's just so much out there in the
world I mean people just oh yeah well
it's crazy I mean I spent half my day
watching mentally unwell people do you
know go to the mailbox and do regular
stuff I know and so it's like yeah it's
crazy because like you said Lucas Nelson
right with somebody who had done a
collab with is somebody yep uh Willie
Nelson's son okay he is and Ray Lynn he
has a daughter too right
um I haven't met I actually have not
even met Lucas in person yet either we
uh
but you guys did a collab together we
did a collab together
um so you go in at separate times and do
it yeah he actually he lives in Hawaii
half the year yep he lives out there and
uh we facetimed and and got it done but
I mean he's such a cool dude is he he
don't even know how cool he is oh man
he's that kind of cool that's the best
kind of cool yeah that's cool that's
cool bro
yeah I think um but yeah like um oh dang
what was I saying oh
he's talking about like the faceless
like the disconnect well yeah so to get
people to see you right it's funny
because you could say his name I've
heard his name before right but it's
like yeah I wouldn't be able to put his
face it's hard you gotta get sent you
have to there's just so much but this
you know some of these like I could pick
out this one dude who has like
you know there's like a guy who's kind
of mentally handicapped and he opens
baseball cards all day and I if I saw
that dude I would lose my mind yeah it's
just crazy how you have you know
different things you're into or there's
a baby there's actually two babies if I
saw one of those babies you'd be like
I would dude you're gonna get arrested
yeah he would have to call me cops like
the baby's dad would be like hey you
gotta stop yeah yeah you gotta stop that
baby's real young but it's true but it's
like just the thing to take your in take
your attention well I think you've got
everybody's attention now I don't know
how you could ever get rid of it I mean
once I heard your voice I don't think I
could ever thank you man I could just
it's in my ears forever thanks you know
it is very powerful thank you very much
and uh thank you so much for uh just
spending time with us absolutely I'm
gonna do this again
[Music]
gonna take